(upbeat music playing)
- [Kelly] You backing in, I like it.
(audience cheering)
- I see you up there, I see
your hat game popping off.
I see you over there.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Hat game guys always show love.
Hat game guy.
- Yeah, hat game guy.
I love hats, I don't
even know how many I own.
- You know.
- [Kelly] That's how many.
- I'm a hat game guy and
I'm a cleft chin guy.
I see another guy walking
around with a cleft chin.
I say cleft brother.
(all laughing)
They got a little hole with
it, little hole in the chin.
- Do they ever pause and just go, huh?
- Sometimes they do.
(Kelly laughing)
Some people forget they
got a clef in their chin.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I said, I said, Yo man,
you got a hole in your chin.
Oh, what up cleft brother, they show love.
(all laughing)
- So wait, I hear that you're
obsessed with cowboy boots,
as well, which I'm Texan
so I love this about you.
- I must have 40 or 50
pairs of cowboy boots.
- Really?
- I remember doing a show one time
and now this is before I
could afford the good boots.
I won't even say the name
or the brand that I had,
but I was loving cowboy boots so much
that I bought a kind of
a reasonable price pair.
- Yeah.
- And I'm doing a show
I forgot what college it was,
or it was a theater, and my heel came off.
- What?
- My whole damn heel
came off during a show.
And I said,
"Oh my God, my heel came off,"
and crowd lost it.
They lost it,
"Ah, his heel came off ahhh."
And I proceeded to do my
whole, I had 45 minutes left.
I did a whole show with one heel on,
but I would refer to
the heel that came off
through the whole show.
- Yep.
- That show could only happen one time.
- It's like a present.
- I can't even repeat that
show unless I intentionally
unscrew my heel, make it loose
and then let it come off,
you know, accidentally
on purpose, you know?
- I know, I've never had that
happen with a cowboy boot.
That would be an awkward gait, yeah.
It would present an awkward walk.
- It was the most amazing show because
something about being
in a moment with people,
that's genuine.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you ain't gonna
never see this again.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Me performing with one heel on my shoe
ain't gonna happen again.
- Yeah.
- And I always tell people all the time,
you sell yourself first,
then you sell what you do.
And I think that's a genuine
thing that you can get
from people who like us,
who provide something to make you happy.
- Yeah, I think we all
miss that live atmosphere
'cause of COVID.
- [Smoove] Yeah.
- And now we really appreciate it.
Speaking of connection, though,
is it 15 years that you just
celebrated with your wife?
- Oh, 15 years.
- Congratulations.
(audience cheering)
But y'all have been
together for over 20, right?
- [Smoove] Been together 20.
Yeah, been together 20.
And now 15 years.
- [Kelly] Look at her beautiful smile.
- My girl, I'm a girlfriend.
My girlfriend.
- Oh, I love that, still dating.
- I don't know if I can clear this,
but she loves when I sing
Bobby Brown 'Girlfriend' to her.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She loves it.
♪ I need a girl friend. ♪
- [Kelly] That's your sexy time, okay.
- [Smoove] ♪ Yeah I need her right now ♪
- You gotta have, you see,
I think it's like this,
you got to, even when you married,
you have to have a
girlfriend/boyfriend relationship
with your companion because
it just keeps it fresh
all the time.
You're always courting
somebody, you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And that's what we have fun.
We really have fun.
And you know, I call her my sunshine.
That's my, that's my boo my boo, my boo.
- I love that.
Your sunshine.
So what you always say
that she's your rock.
So what's something that
you think you wouldn't
have gotten through like without her?
- Oh man.
This, this whole industry, this, you know
you know how it is,
it's huge.
It's a lot that goes into this.
And I think, you know,
having support of someone
is the number one thing
you need in this business.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Is having a companion who's supportive.
Oh, look at the 'stashe!
Oh!
And now this is on our
anniversary in Cabo, Cabo Wabo.
- I've never been to Cabo.
I've heard it's awesome.
- What?
- [Kelly] I know.
I was supposed to go
like twice and I, yeah.
- Ooh let me set you up.
- Oh I was real set up.
I even paid for half of it.
- I've got a brand new Montage out there.
Anytime you want to go, you let me know.
My guy Neil over there he's
a spectacular over there.
- I hear it's beautiful.
- It is beautiful.
And this hotel is spectacular.
It's like two or three years old
and I think we all need
some place to go to.
We go to the Montage in Cabo,
and then for my birthday every year
we go to the Montage in Deer Valley.
- Now I've been to a Montage.
- Oh my gosh.
- Br br br.
That's a nice, yeah.
- I'm a winter baby.
I like to ski.
- Oh, I have a ranch in the mountains.
- I get on the slope like this,
I get all like this that's how I do it.
- Yeah.
You know what I do?
- I do a jump sometimes like this.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
I jump, but my landing is not good.
Ooh.
(audience applauding)
- So your new Netflix show
is called Blockbuster.
Is it about a Blockbuster?
- [Smoove] It's about
the last Blockbuster.
- Who do you play in Blockbuster?
- I play Percy.
I am a business owner
and I basically own this whole strip mall.
Blockbuster just happens to be
one of the businesses there.
Now Randall Park plays one my best friend,
but I'm also his landlord, basically.
- Yeah.
- So I gotta balance friendship
and business with this dude
constantly, you know?
It's different going into
business with a friend, you know.
But, 'cause I got a business to run.
I gotta run all this, man.
You my friend,
now I'm trying to help you.
I hope you survive.
I really do hope this
Blockbuster's here forever.
But right now you're going
through trouble times
trying to keep it open.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think the uniqueness
of the show is the funny,
it's funny,
has a lot of heart.
And I think heart is the
thing that I love the most
about this show,
is the heart.
And I think, you know, as
a comedian-actor, you know,
there's not too many chances
I get to take a swing
at my chops,
to show my chops.
- Yeah, pull on the heart strings.
- [Smoove] Yeah pull on the heartstrings.
And I think you're gonna
be really surprised
at everyone's performance on this show,
but definitely gonna be
surprised by my relationship
with my daughter,
which is going to be really fun
to see us as we dive into that,
you know, during the season.
Really a fun show.
And me and Randall have history
'cause we worked together
on Fresh Off the Boat,
but it's the friendship that we had
that gave me another opportunity
to work with him again.
- Yeah, good chemistry.
- And the phone keeps ringing.
The phone keeps ringing
because you, you know,
you're nice to each other.
You show up on time, you stay late.
All the good things that.
- I like organic networking.
You know, it's not like too
LA or anything like that.
It's organic, it's like, Oh
no, we actually mesh well.
That's cool.
- Yeah.
And it's almost sad that
the young people now
don't get a chance to see a lot of that,
or to work on that in their, you know,
'cause everything's so fast nowadays.
- Right.
- You don't get a chance
to smell the roses.
You know?
So all those little things
you don't think about,
I don't think about it now,
but when I really look back
on the movement and how, you know,
you get to a certain
point, it all made sense.
I wouldn't change it for the world.
- No, me neither.
It's funny though 'cause our kids
are super like, they're like,
"Oh well can't you just order it?"
And I'm like, sure go get
your wallet and I will,
I'll help you out, I'll
make the phone call.
You can put in your credit card number.
- Yeah.
- They just think that the stork
brings everything to our house.
- They don't, they don't
know any other way.
They haven't experienced
any other way of doing it.
- I was like, and that is
the definition of privilege.
I was like, wow, that's amazing.
Well wait, you're doing standup right now,
so how's that going?
'Cause everybody had to
take off for a bit right?
- Everybody had to take
off a little bit you know.
This is like, I started
and stopped three times
because of everything that's going on.
But now I'm back with my
Physical Therapy Tour.
We are, I'm about five shows in right now.
I'm gonna do another five
before end of the year
and then we are gonna
re-up in the new year.
You know, and it's been so fun.
I'm doing the New York Comedy Festival
that's coming up in November.
November the 11th.
That's gonna be one of
my big ones at town hall.
That's gonna be so fun.
- I love that you're still
so passionate about it.
That's awesome 'cause you
said you've been doing it
so many years,
like some people can get jaded.
That's cool.
- Everything is 200% for me.
Everything.
- I love that.
We only live one.
- You really do.
- Yeah, enjoy it.
All right, let's do a few commercials.
J.B's new show Blockbuster
is now on Netflix
and you can catch him on
his Physical comedy tour.
Look for tickets online, everybody.